Hey, what's going on? It's bill burr
and this is the Thursday afternoon,
Monday morning podcast. Just
before Friday afternoon. And
okay.
Just checking it on you.
What's going on for July 2nd,
2015 happy birthday to America.
Happy Birthday too.
Woo Woo America.
Happy Birthday,
Uncle Sam,
me happy birthday
to you.
Go Fuck Yourself. All right.
It's, it's just, it's,
it's the fucking birthday of this country.
And you know what that means, right?
You get out there and your true,
you get yourself a bag old barker,
undo your fucking top button and most of
your zipper let that belly but it walk
around.
I'll tell you what,
4th of July in Los Angeles I will tell
you is like no other place seriously.
Like they, they, it's an
absolute fucking free for all.
You can shoot off essentially
whatever the fuck you want,
wherever you want,
regardless of safety. And uh,
we are now in the fourth year evidently
of the drought and I knew that we were
having water issues. I didn't realize
that it was the fourth year because a,
either I wasn't paying attention or raw,
they're finally starting to report on it.
So it is dry as can be,
you know.
Okay.
Dry is a fucking white guys torso.
Um, anyways, so I am predicting,
once again, last year was the first time,
you know, I go up, I go up on the roof,
I go up on the roof and I
watched the fireworks. You know,
I fucking put a little lawn chair down.
This is the end of the day, right?
And I just sit up there and I smoke
a cigar and I have my fucking,
my Miller high life plural.
Exactly.
I have a hell of a time getting
back down because there's, you know,
the only way to get up on the roof
is by a ladder. Right. So, um,
but I just sit up there and I just, I
just watch all of them going off. And uh,
I think it was last year. The year
before was the first time I saw it.
I saw some something,
basically fireworks show Worthy
Litton Lid off by just some jackass.
On a street that has a bunch of
palm trees and apartment buildings.
And I saw it explode and it started to
go out and then it started to go up again
and we were all standing up.
They're going to set on fire
is that fucking place on fire?
Fortunately was right around the block
from the fire station and I gotta Tell Ya,
I gotta hand it to the a l
La f d the fire department,
that fucking thing caught on fire there.
There uh,
sirens came on within the
minute and they were over there.
The whole thing was done within like
swear to God, two or three minutes,
which was incredible. And I couldn't
tell from where I was at if it was a, a,
a tree or what don't. I just sound
like the awful reporter on site. No,
I don't know if that's a tree,
if it's an apartment or a Parthenon,
but whatever it is, it is definitely
on fire. Back to you, Chad.
Thank you. Wilamena she's a
new addition. Transgender,
transgender ginger from Massachusetts.
Will Amena Bird. Wilamena wa.
We just want to say how much we
support what you are doing. Um,
anyways, uh, so I got him, oh,
did I get into with somebody?
I think I had some good shows this week.
There was no fucking problems. You know,
it was just said to that couple last
week that got offended when I got mad.
And I use that word that I should have
said, well what if I said this word,
which was a different bad word for
another group of people. You know,
it's funny you wouldn't of got
offended and you'd be standing here,
slapped me on my back saying what a
funny edgy show it was. Oh, Billy,
you still not over it now I'm not.
I'm not.
So anyways,
I'm going to do a little bit of
grilling this weekend and uh,
got some family over here seeing all the
pressure right. You take out your grill,
you gotta make sure you fucking,
you're doing it right. Not like Versie.
He'll just let anybody
jump on his fucking grill.
Maybe that's the genius of [inaudible].
I don't know,
but I'm going simple this year.
I was going to do the whole fucking pork
shoulder and all that and I just been
so fucking busy. I'm like, you
know what, at the end of the day,
how drunk people are going to be.
Did they really need anything more
than fucking burgers and hot dogs?
I remember one year for the Rose Bowl,
j law had smoked a pork shoulder,
which evidently was delicious,
but by the time he took it
out I was so shit faced.
I had already started my cigar,
like the meal had already happened.
So then he gave it to me and I was sitting
in a fucking lawn chair with a beer
in one hand,
a cigar in the other and I was trying
to figure out how to set down one or the
other so I could pick at it. It was an
absolute shit show. So I don't know what,
why go through that effort?
I didn't what the fuck I'm talking about.
So anyways, I'm happy 4th of July
to everybody and I hope you have a,
even if you're around the world
and it doesn't mean shit to you,
you know what I mean?
Like,
I had never heard of Cinco de
Mayo until I came out here to la.
And I actually asked the classic White
Guy Question, what day is Cinco de Mayo?
For those of you who are like me,
that basically means in
Spanish it means 5th of May.
It's like the 4th of July and say what
does the 4th of July? That's what,
that's what I was, I was that
person. Well actually no,
because I didn't say the
whole thing in Spanish.
So that'd be a 4th of July, right, bill?
We get it. We get it. So anyways, um,
being a lover of all things old,
uh,
one of the frustrations of that is
every day, you know, something happens.
I have my old truck,
68 f 100 and I have my old house,
which was made in the 19 fucking twenties.
And uh,
if it's not one thing, it's a fuck
another. And some days it's both.
Like today I started my day, I had to go
do some, um, look at some of the writing.
Some of the drawings for F
is for family by the way,
which is coming out in December. We
got three episodes, three episodes in.
It's a serialized, um, series,
meaning basically each,
you know, they don't stand alone like the
Simpsons. So this is going to be like,
uh, it's going to be like
watching true detective,
except it's a cartoon and it's not as
gritty. I don't know how to describe it.
I think it's going to be fucking funny.
So I went down there today to go look at,
so I got my truck and um,
yeah,
and I don't know what
happened this morning.
I come down and stay at me
because I left it on a hill.
And you gearheads know this. I
had my tarp in the, on the, uh,
passenger's side floor and I go to take
out the top. I need to wash it anyways,
so I didn't have it on my truck. As I get
my truck wash and I throw the top one,
then it gets dirty. So
long fucking story. So, um,
I go to pick it up and it's covered
in like not covered, but it's,
there's a bunch of antifreeze leaked out
from underneath the, from the dashboard,
uh, area. Now I know I have,
the way the heating system works,
I have a heater coil right behind my
glove box that I had to replace it.
I don't know if, I don't know why
any that'd be antifreeze in there.
I have no fucking idea.
I don't really understand the coolest
system belong beyond what it does for the,
the engine block. But anyways,
there it was, it was all of that.
And I hadn't watered up when a
time I realized it was on the tarp.
I already headed against
my shirt and my pants.
I had a light pair of gray pants on and
I was just like, yeah, you know what?
Fuck it.
So I toss that thing aside and I go to
work and I'm joking with people laugh and
I go, I've got a brand new fucking
engine in there. Like, how,
how could I have a fucking problem?
You know why?
Because the fucking things almost
50 years old. That's why bill,
you get out of bed every morning,
no matter how good a night's sleep,
you got some fucked up on you while
you're driving. You're driving you bill.
That's what you're doing. So
then I come home, all right,
picked up one of my family
members down the airport,
fucking when I've got a burger and a beer,
they make the best burgers out
here in La, I have to say. And uh,
I backed into the driveway and I get out
of the truck cause I got to close the
gate and I grabbed the handle and the
fucking handle comes off on the gates. So,
you know, I've, uh, I don't
what, what, what, why,
why buy thinks, why do you buy shit? So
then it just fucking breaks down. But, um,
I didn't want to get into it.
So anyway,
so we got all these
fucking people over here,
so it's going to be
really stressful. And, uh,
we got to figure out what the fuck we're
going to put everybody and all of this
bullshit.
And um,
okay.
I don't know. My, me and my wife kind
of pining kind of me getting into it,
you know what I mean? She bought one of
these fucking pull out fucking sofas.
I remember a long time ago, Todd, Barry,
you stupid this perfect joke about the
pullout bed self a cause they gonna stick
it in my office. Right. And of course
there's no fucking room for there.
There's no room for it. So now, uh, you
know, it was just like, you know what?
Fuck it. I'll get rid of my desk.
I don't need an office. Anyways.
Whenever I do the podcast, I do it in the
bedroom anyways, laying down on the bed.
I don't need an office. You know,
you got an office, you know,
I'll just fucking use yours.
I mine.
So whatever it Todd Barry,
you said this great joke about the fucking
pullout couch where he was just going
like, uh, you know, you know, he's
like a pullout couch. He goes,
it's an uncomfortable couch that pulls
out to an even more uncomfortable bed.
I'm butchering it. But I used to
always laugh because it was perfect.
I was living in New York City at the time.
We all had small apartments and you know,
you'd hook up with somebody or go over
some chicks house and Hook over a house
or fucking apartment and you'd be at one
of those fucking things and you'd be on,
you know, you'd be a healthy snack,
a healthy scratch, you'd be fuck,
you wouldn't be playing the next
game is basically what I'm saying.
So we're getting one of
those and I haven't slept on
one of those fucking things
since I was 30. I slept on a futon until
I was 36. Not Proud of it, but I did,
I made the sacrifices so I could scream
comments on my own podcast someday.
Right. So I haven't slept
in one of those in a while.
So maybe the technology has gotten
a little better. Um, I dunno.
I have no idea. But, um,
anyways, I not feeling it.
I had nothing to fucking talk about today.
I'm just excited.
I got the whole fucking weekend.
So last week I started to talk about
the Bruins and what dawn Sweeney did and
why they let everybody go. And how I
didn't understand it. And as usual,
they're saying that everybody
wanted like a 50 year contract,
like Douggie Hamilton wanting to get paid,
like the best defenseman in the
league is what they were saying.
And then evidently Lou Cheech wanted
like a fucking eight year contract and
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah. I don't know whether to believe it.
I don't know who shot. I don't know who's
not. And I don't know what to believe.
What this fucking thing.
Oh,
I know is I'm just sitting here
thinking we got rid of Tyler's Sagan,
Johnny Boychuk,
Douggie Hamilton in Milan,
Lou Cheech all in the last three, four
years, three, four seasons I should say.
So, um, I don't know.
I guess we just got some goon from Philly.
I don't know how that helps us.
I don't know how that helps us. I don't
know what the fuck we're doing. I,
I'm not a big fan of draft picks.
I'm a big fan of people
that have proven themselves.
If you think he couldn't
pay one of those guys,
I would have kept blue Cheech and I go,
fuck all you guys sit in and say
that he's not scoring as much.
Nobody's scored as much.
Last year we had a brutal fucking seasons.
Now all of a sudden Milan Lou
teaches that one isn't a fucking guy.
He can build a team around. Sorry.
This is like a delayed reaction.
Think I was just in shock. So, um,
I just feel like next year when I go,
you know, get the center ice package.
When I go to watch the Bruins,
I want to feel like I'm watching the
blue jackets or something that I never
fucking watch. No disrespect to all you
hockey fans there in Columbus, Ohio.
Hey, y'all wish you fans. You guys getting
a little nervous about a hard bother.
Is it John Harbaugh captain? Come
back, bring it fucking Michigan Beck.
He's starting to hear those horns playing.
Listen to it.
Listen to it this weekend.
When you're out there with the fireworks,
right and you're fucking
Osu championship tee shirt,
you're not going to tell me
that way in the distance.
If the wind's blowing just right, you
know, you're not going to start here
during you guys gonna flip
out. Yay. He won shit. Yeah.
You want shit and fucking are Caribbean
Maribela time you won a championship.
Why would people in Ohio
have a southern accent bill?
I Dunno cause it's
offensive. Um, I'm hoping.
Here's the John Harbaugh bringing
the, uh, is it John Harbaugh?
I can't remember anything anymore.
Uh, the fucking wolverines back.
I hope he does because I would love
to see that become a rivalry again.
You know what I mean? It's like, you know,
Brian's contains as much as
I should and the Canadians,
it's no fun when the Canadian stink.
You want to beat them when
they're good or at least you know,
their version of good now,
which as well, you know,
we want a couple rounds of the playoffs,
poor bastards,
poor French best. It's, um, I'm actually
going to be up there later on this month.
I'm doing a Gig in Ottawa and
then September I'm doing Toronto.
So that's the extent of my Canadian shit
that I'm going to be doing this year.
And, um, for those of you who
want to complain, ah, relax.
All right,
the way global warming is going,
your country will be a fun place to
tour within eight months, you know,
so who knows? Maybe I'll be up
there. Maybe I will be maybe a, well,
so, uh, anyways,
let me do a little bit of advertising
here and see if I can get this fucking
thing back on the rails.
A Hulu,
everybody for the first time,
you can now stream the entire
Seinfeld series exclusively on Hulu.
That's every episode,
all nine seasons,
all streaming on Hulu
for seven 99 a month.
Visit hulu.com and sign up to get
access to all of your favorite Seinfeld
episodes again for seven 99 a month.
You can watch all nine seasons of
Seinfeld with your Hulu subscription.
And the last quick read here is
zip, zip recruiter. Are you hiring?
But not sure where to find the
best candidates. Will, are Ya?
Okay.
As a business owner,
I can tell you that your company is
only as good as the people you hire.
Geez, Bill, what insight? You
mean if I hire a bunch of morons,
my company's still won't be good.
I can also tell you that posting your
job in one place isn't enough to find
quality candidates, but when
you're, you're short staffed,
there's no time to deal with the dozens
of different jobs sites until now.
Thanks to zip recruiter.com um,
I can post to 100 plus job
sites with one single click.
Why are you saying that? I mean, I know
I can do it, but why would I do it?
I don't have any employees. If I were to
want employees, this is what I would do.
Just post once and within 24 hours.
Watch your candidates roll into zip
recruiter. Easiest ZipRecruiter's,
easy to use interface plus be instantly
matched to candidates from over 4
million resumes.
Ziprecruiter has been used by over 400,000
businesses and you can try it right
now for free. Getting the right people
for your company is so important.
Try ZipRecruiter and get your perfect
candidate before they go to somebody else.
Today you can try ZipRecruiter for free.
I literally,
the way I'm reading this is
like the way walking does align.
Like could anybody here a period in
any punctuation in any of that? Uh,
go to ziprecruiter.com/bar.
That's ziprecruiter.com/burr again,
ziprecruiter.com/burr
oh you know,
this whole podcast,
I've been sitting here trying to wonder
what the fuck it was that I needed to
talk about, which is probably why the
first 10 minutes was so goddamn bad.
My apologies. How can I do that on
the, on the birthday of this nation,
you know, so, um,
the native Americans have like
a 4th of July type of thing.
They must have had their holidays, right?
Did we take those away from them to,
you know, anyways, fucking
horrible. Let's plow ahead here.
I need to apologize,
specifically heartfelt apologies from
the lovely Nia to the person last week
that wrote the quite the hypothetical
about p diddy and the Kettlebell and 50
million bucks. It just
seems so fucking random. Um,
I think we were out of the country when
that whole thing happened or I don't
know what we were doing,
but we missed.
For those of you who also live under a
rock or maybe just have better shit to do
with your life.
Uh,
P diddy was arrested on East UCLAs campus
Monday for getting into a fight with a
Bruins assistant coach early Monday
afternoon and later charged with three
counts of assault with a deadly weapon.
One count of making terrorist's
threats and one count of battery making
terrorist's threats. What
does that fucking Marty all
family, you know, it's shit.
You yell when you're mad.
Terrorist's threats.
The fuck constitutes is
terrorist threat at this point.
I have an a bottled water
and your carry on. Um, yes.
You read that correctly and yes,
that p diddy and then of
course the snarky comment,
he'll always be puff daddy
to me. Oh, Sam Cooper. Um,
did he son Justin Combs is a red shirt.
Junior defensive back for the Bruins.
He's that fucking old.
I remember living in Manhattan when he,
when he was a kid and did, he had that
fucking a restaurant called Justin's.
He was a little kid and he used to do
standup down there and p diddy would come
in there and he would heckle the
fucking comics. It was a brutal gig. Um,
he's played in seven games
combined over the past two seasons.
This is his kid registering
for tackles according to a,
um, these people here, one of us,
you see Las assistant coaches was
at Justin on the field and did,
he later confronted the coach
and grabbed him as a result.
Diddy 45 was arrested for assault and
remains in custody at the campus jail.
Isn't that fucking hilarious?
Who would have thought that Sean
Combs was a helicopter parent?
Shouldn't you be if like flipping
out at like his pop Warner game?
It's like he's a man now.
I don't know.
Maybe it's hard fucking watching your
kid getting screamed at. I have no idea.
Ucla later confirmed the report
and said that, uh, Sean Combs,
let's just use his real name, was charged
with assault with a deadly weapon.
With the weapon being a kettle bell,
uh,
a piece of weightlifting equipment for
all you fucking lazy bastards out there.
Um, here's Uclas full statement. Shortly
after 12:30 PM today, Sean Combs,
Aka p diddy was the rest of that,
a Costa athletic training camp.
We, we've already running,
we already know this shit.
He said,
I'm thankful that our staff showed the
level of professionalism that they did in
handling the situation.
Well. How difficult was it?
It's a bunch of football people. Here's
a picture of what, what are you doing?
You know,
at some point you just gotta give into
the fact that your kid's not going to
make the pros sit there
attack. Then, uh, uh,
a fucking assistant coach get your Goddamn
head in the game and all of a sudden,
do you think he did one of those
little ditty dances? You know, it was,
he came over.
You remember that thing he did when he
bent over at the waist and kind of just
walked up with his shoulders
going up and down the p, the APP,
the Di,
the why the fucking datey hold up.
Remember that?
And that guy from a meet the parents,
Ben Kingsley Bent, uh, Ben Fucking,
uh, Ben. A sizzle,
which Ben Shenanigans.
Ben Stiller.
Ben Stiller was in that fucker.
All right.
He did the whole beginning thing fade
Leptin and like he was his neighbor and
then Sean Combs did his, his,
what he thinks is hilarious,
that dead pan look at the camera and
turns his head to the side and you could
just hear all the white people laughing
like it was the funniest thing ever.
Oh ha ha ha. Instead of
going like, listen, Shawn,
Mr. Combs, I, I want
to tell you that sucks.
But you had just gotten into that
incident where you're saying the gun was
shines. Is that his name?
Remember that guy who went to
jail? That's back. When did,
he was still banging a, what's her face
there? The chick from the Jennifer Lopez,
right before she was with Ben Affleck
before she was with the fucking backup
dancer before she got with the fucking,
that fucking guy that looks
like Latino Anthony [inaudible].
What the fuck was that guy's name? What
did he sing? He sang one of the east,
sang all those fucking,
oh Jesus.
What the fuck was that guy's name?
Piazza Dora.
Ah, fuck. It's something junior,
isn't it? Freddie Prinze Jr. Okay,
I don't fuck. Well, what are you going
to do? What are you going to do that?
You know what?
It's unfortunate.
Okay.
Parents, I'm not a parent, so I can
say this with confidence. You know,
I can say this without prejudice.
Sometimes you kids just can't play
it the next level. Yeah. Well,
you just gotta you,
you gotta deal with it and they're
going to get yelled at at the collegiate
level because you think that assistant
coach wants to be the assistant coach for
the rest of his life. He doesn't.
He wants to be the head coach.
Then he wants to get to the pros.
That's what he wants to do.
And sometimes your kids getting
in the way, that dream, you know,
and they, they got it. They
got to yell at him. So, uh,
I know I'm going to go out on a limb
having not seen any of the footage to say
that. Obviously there was a
complete fucking overreaction,
but I will say that no terrorist threat
was fucking made under the definition of
the law. I'm sure it was a
terrible terrorist threat. Look,
I'll kill your whole family or something.
You know,
I'll blow this fucking place
up like people you sit.
That's just an expression
for now is growing up.
Burn this fat burning the run
down. Next thing you know, rights.
Fucking people step off for buying the
bushes and you put it on a most wanted
list. Hey, here's a bet
I'd be willing to make.
I'm not making it, but I'm willing
to make it with one person.
I'll bet anybody out there $1,000 that
at no point during this next presidential
election,
at no point will anybody who has a serious
chance at becoming the next president
of the United States at all.
Will they bring up all fucking
it and he taught Monsanto there.
Nobody's going to bring that shit up.
Is they're sitting there charging p
diddy with with making terrorist threats.
Is that what it is?
Meanwhile these guys are fucking up
the whole food supply for their own
countrymen. It's the
biggest like act of treason,
terrorism, whatever you want to
fucking call it. Do you know?
They just pass the fucking law.
Okay.
The house votes.
This is how underpaid politicians are
and rich people get him into office
corporations and all this shit.
How's votes to repeal meat labeling law
under threat of retaliation from Canada
and Mexico,
we basically passed a law that was going
to say that we don't have to say where
the meat comes from.
You haven't,
so you basically have no idea
what the fuck you're eating.
Under threat of trade relations
from Canada and Mexico,
the House has voted to repeal a law
requiring country of origin labels on
packages of beef,
pork and poultry.
Okay.
Wait, Canada and Mexico are arguing. Oh
wait, wait a minute. Wait, Whoa, whoa.
So Canada and Mexico also have fucked
up food so they don't want that either.
Okay,
so this is the end.
This is the end of the fucking world.
The World Trade Organization rejected
at US appeal last month ruling that the
labels that say were animals were born,
raised in slaughter,
are discriminatory against the
two u s border countries. Oh yeah.
Don't bring in your fucking genetically
altered food and fuck with ours yet.
Cons.
Uh,
both have said they planned to talk
to the World Trade Organization for
permission to impose billions of
dollars in tariffs on American goods.
Well, joke's on you buddy. We
don't make anything here anymore.
I don't know that we export anything
other than fucked up food. Right.
I don't know. But anyways, I
guarantee you that, um, you know,
if I every once in a while, if I read a
story before he started talking about it,
um,
okay.
I, I guarantee you nobody's
going to bring that up.
I doubt anybody's going to bring up that
Nestle doesn't think that a water is a
human right and that corporations are
in the process of trying to privatize
water.
Yeah.
So,
you know,
I don't know if it rains and you stick
your tongue out your own money. It's just,
it's going down. It's why I was
talking about it. I did that, that, um,
needed too many stars.
I was joking around where I,
the president should have fuck you money.
He should make 400 grand a year.
If that guy could feel good about where
he's going to be at the end of his,
you know, if for eight years
you made 400 grand every year.
Okay. Do you think you'd be set
for life walking out in your 50s?
You know,
there's no fucking way.
And that they go around and they give
those speeches after they've, their PR,
their president to these
fucking corporations that
got him in and they get $1
million a night and that's that
stem washing their bribe money.
And that's how they, they, they
take care of them. I don't know.
I know I'm going down the fucking Reva.
Notice that guys,
I'm slowly going back down the
rabbit hole again. Just cause I know,
I know another fucking election
is coming up. Uh, they will,
they won't talk about any of
that shit. So when he was, well,
what can I talk about that's a
little happier than that? Um, Oh,
last night I'm getting ready for
another goddamn comedy jam. And uh,
I, um, I played for like two hours.
I got fucking blisters on my fingers.
I don't know if it's cause I'm just
hadn't played in a minute because I was
focusing on the helicopter shit.
But it was the most God damn
fun I've had in so long.
Two hours in this rehearsal space.
We went through all the songs that
we had done on the previous ones. Uh,
all these fucking 80 songs.
Dr Feelgood,
Paradise City custard Pie.
What else are we doing now?
And so now we're working on new one. Uh,
I know I never tell you what the song is,
so, um, I'm, I'm getting geared
up to do that again and uh, oh,
I can't tell you that this is nothing
more fun than playing fucking drums if you
don't have a good time playing drums.
So you were an asshole. I mean,
I am an asshole. I don't
know. Well wait a second,
you don't have take.
The problem with this podcast was I had
one beer before I did it about an hour
ago, and that's enough for guy, a guy
of my age, a man of a certain age.
If you have one beer in the
afternoon, you're done. You're done.
You got to take a fucking nap. Let's
end on this everybody. Mercedes AMG.
That's like the Shelby division. No, no.
I don't mean to insult Mercedes by
comparing them to an American car.
And now how insulting that is.
You know,
I met some German girl and I was
talking about, uh, I was on the road,
this German woman. I was going like, Oh
man, do you guys get great cars? Like BMW?
She goes, Audi and I go Mercedes. And
then she just rolled her eyes. She goes,
it's a cab. Like it's a taxi
because when you go over there,
like that's what all their taxis are.
So they don't even fucking respect them.
I'm saying, AMG, we'll build
something fast as a given, uh, that's,
it's specialty.
But in this instance,
a suitably vague teaser video
has piqued our interest.
Evidently they're making some sort of v
eight they don't know what the fuck it
is. I'll have the link for this. You
guys want to hear what it sounds like.
This is their little teaser here.
Okay,
AMG. Something fast as coming. Come on.
Come on.
Show me the fucking car.
You know what?
I'm not showing you that because that was
just a waste of 19 seconds of my life,
you know? Fuck you. I'm glad
you lost both wars. Your cons,
I think something fast as common.
You supposed to your AMG, right?
You know what? This is a complete
cluster. Fuck. I apologize to check in.
You walk in on you the way I did
this week. Did I even ask you?
I mean I'm supposed to
be checking in on you.
I didn't ask you about anything like
how was your work week? You know,
are they making your work the Friday?
Are they making you work the third your
boss makes you do now don't blame you
fucking boss and like whoever's the shot
collar. You've got to figure out who,
who's the fucking evil cunt that won't
give you the half day on the third.
Right.
Cause you know businesses psych that
the 4th of July is on Saturday and how
great. We don't have to give him
a fucking day off. Fuck them.
Make them come in Friday.
Tell him to stay till five 30 find
out who the shot caller is and a,
I don't know. You gotta you gotta do
something fucking stupid. You know,
maybe you'd take whatever condiment you
were going to put on your hot dog that
day and you stick it
under his door handles.
That's such a chick Conti fucking
thing to do. But it is hilarious.
Now.
Whatever you do,
don't make a youtube video of it and then
send it to me and then you're going to
get caught.
Just don't do that.
But I'm just saying it's
gotta be something you can.
Okay.
Is it considered an act of terrorism
now to do the old gag where you put the
bucket of water over somebody's
door? You know, why did that go away?
I think it was considered
hack after awhile,
but it's still is one of the funniest
fucking things ever to see somebody
standing there and not in swim trunks
dressed ready to go to work and have a
bucket of water go over their head.
Right. It's an act of terrorism.
Do you support Isis? Um, oh Jesus.
Bill. Oh yeah, that's this, you know,
it's this podcast. This was, I should have
renamed this podcast. Who, oh, JJ, gosh,
maybe I don't have enough to
talk about. You know, it is.
I got off the fucking finally,
um,
I got off the road and uh,
I haven't had to do shit.
I think I did one show this
week. Is that all I did? I Dunno.
I'm gearing up for the Montreal
Comedy Festival and uh,
I'm doing some God forsaken Gig in Ottawa,
which is either going to be amazing or
it's going to be an absolute shit show.
I think it's some sort of
blues festival or something.
I'm just picturing a bunch of bikers.
You know,
the only thing worse than a bunch of
bikers is a bunch of Canadian bikers,
you know, cause at least the ones down
here, they're frightening. You know,
up there that probably all find out.
Jesus. Why, why would I do that?
Why would I say that before I go up there
and then you have to prove how fucking
tough they are. You know, that's
got to be weird, right? Joanie?
No fucking biker gang. It's like, am I
seriously going to do this with my life?
What are you doing? Hey, I haven't seen
him since high school. What do you do?
I'm going to count. What do
you do? I'm in a biker gang.
Yeah. Making my money. Yes. Selling
drugs and a prostituting women,
you know, you know the office
area. It just wasn't for me.
I tried the cubicle thing and uh,
I dunno.
Then I just started getting tattoos.
It started with the, you know,
the classic early 90 ones,
you know,
I got a tramp stamp and Barb wire
around my fucking arm and then I just
continued. Okay. Next
thing you know, I dunno.
Oxy came out right. I was sick a crank
anyways. Right? Oxy came out and then,
and then here we go.
By the way,
did anybody see what Eddie van Halen
said this week? Eddie van Halen.
I swear to God, man, that guy
is like, he's becoming the good,
do you guys ever see that,
that documentary,
but beware of Mr. Baker and this is
whole thing on ginger Baker who a,
I'm obviously a big fan of,
um,
I mean the guy just comes off as one of
the most psychotic fucking human beings
you wouldn't ever want to be around.
And I hate to say it,
that was just watching Eddie.
I'm so fucking old. I don't
want, it was a young guy,
25 year old kid just redefining the
guitar and just to watch him turning into
this grumpy old man.
I guess there's some sort of horse shit
going on between him and the Bass player,
Michael Anthony.
I know he's not in the band anymore.
I don't know what happened this week.
But Eddie basically said like,
you know what,
if van Halen fans don't shut the fuck up,
I'll bring back Gary Sharon
as the lead vocalist.
That'll give him something to bitch about
and it's just like Jesus Christ. Dude,
you had to shit on Gary and fucking
do anything. How'd you drag him?
Is that his name? I don't
know. Like fuck his name is.
It's just really stat enough.
So like Eddie just go play the
guitar and shut the fuck up man.
I don't understand what, what's this
guy's problem is? Let me see something.
Let me, let me get the exact goddamn
quote here. Then I swear to God,
I'll get out of your way. What do
you care? Even though this will,
this one kind of sucked this week.
He got admit to short fucking weak.
If you have a boss with a, uh, who
has a heart, you know what I mean?
They let off for the Friday.
Who's getting it?
We don't make anything here anyways.
What are you taking a day off from?
Answering phones,
you know,
calling up China and tell him to have the,
the crying people in the background who
build the shit for no money to shut the
fuck up while you listen to
some spreadsheet numbers. Sorry,
I have no, I'm just, I'm totally, I'm
just back into this shit. All right.
Michael Anthony, Eddie
van Halen. Here we go.
Why do we got something fast? It's coming.
Can you believe that? Fucking that,
that was like clickbait.
Okay.
And when you see this car,
it's going to change your whole
attitude on what cars could be.
Um,
where was it?
Yeah.
No, Jesus Christ. There's
so much fucking drama.
So this is when you look up Eddie
van Halen. Michael Anthony. This is,
this is the front page.
This is how much fucking chick yelling
and screaming is going on in this band.
Michael Anthony says it's really sad.
He hasn't spoken to.
I don't want the rest of this is Gary
Sherman reflects on his three year stint
and Van Halen.
David Lee Roth vents about van Halen
[inaudible] future a Sammy Hagar defends
Michael Anthony.
Um,
Sammy Hagar predicts Michael
Anthony will rejoin van Halen.
Uh, Sammy Hagar defends Michael
Anthony. Fuck you, Eddie.
Michael. Anthony. I never quit. Van Halen.
Ladies. Ladies, can we just get back
to running with the devil there?
Can we just do that? Um, I got
the greatest reality show ever.
You take fucking Eddie
van Halen and axl rose.
All right.
But then you'd have Steven Adler play
the Donald Trump role as who gets fired
from the fucking band, you know,
or whatever. It gets annoying.
Maybe I didn't have a great idea.
Maybe I had it.
I just thought of the people and I
thought it was great. Speaking of which,
you see Donald Trump got fired
from his own fucking show.
I actually think that he's getting
paid by the Illuminati is a distraction
because I absolutely fucking love this
guy in this election and I don't give a
fuck what he says. At least he's saying
something different as opposed to right.
Yeah. Yesterday I said to Kate yet,
right? There's cadre great again. Right?
I just liked it.
He just sounds like some fucking
drunk in a bar with his simple stupid
solutions.
Okay.
Hey, uh, Trump, what about the hole
in the ozone where I get a ladder?
Yeah,
we'll draw this country. Everybody's
afraid to get a ladder. She's like,
what are you talking about?
You know,
they can't get ladders because of the
Koreans and there are a bunch of rapists.
He is literally sounds like he's like
dead guy at closing time where everybody's
going like, oh Jesus, is he gonna Puke?
Let's get this guy a fucking cab. Um,
somebody please explain to me how that
guy's worth $9 billion. I just, I,
for the of me,
I don't buy it.
I really don't show he
his running his Yap,
which is funny.
He's lost his TV show and I think his
clothing line at Macy's and what's the
funniest fucking thing ever
is to watch the network.
They'll issue statements like,
we don't stand by some of the hateful
things that he said about Mexico Mexicans.
And it's like,
fuck you.
You don't stand by losing money and
people are bitching to you and they're
threatening to your fucking advertise as
quit acting like he'd give a fuck about,
about anybody right now. Jesus.
Jesus. I was so fucking negative.
Maybe somebody at the network does
care. Um, all right, so that's it.
I already sang happy birthday to America.
They Canada. When's, when's your uh, oh,
I should have done it on Cinco de Mayo.
Okay.
Right.
Happy Birthday to Mexico.
Bueno birthday day, man. He called. Whoa.
I don't know any you'll tango Pero.
Wow.
You don't think, oh, Pero Greece,
Splunk. I don't fucking know. I don't,
I don't fucking know. What do
you want from me? Both de uh,
I swear to God got at one beer, one beer
and I'm not drunk, but I can't think.
All right, there you go.
There's your podcast. Just yeah,
get it out. Yeah, we got a,
we got some greatest hits coming up here.
Uh,
people please have a happy
and safe holiday. All right.
Booze and fireworks.
Don't work but booze and you're friends
with fireworks definitely works.
So find a safe place for your drunk ass
to watch and blow their fingers off or
light their backyard on fire. All right.
If you're half drunk friends over,
do not have fireworks.
If you're going to your friend's
house and they are drunk and they have
fireworks, let them do what
they want. It's their house.
Just make sure you have enough juice
in your phone to be able to videotape
what's happening, what happens, and
please send it to me here at the, uh,
the man podcast and, um, and that is
it. All right, go. Fuck, I haven't,
God bless you.
I'll talk to you.
A lot of shipments,
gas mileage thing I brought up last week,
how I was watching the good bye girl
and she was standing at the corner of
characters, was standing in
front of a fucking Subaru and uh,
it got 39 miles per gallon and here it
is 36 later and my car only gets fucking
a hybrid,
only gets 41 miles per gallon.
So this brilliant guy writes in and he
goes and he starts talking about leaded
gas and all this fucking
how cars today are heavier.
This fucking Moron thought cars today
were heavier than cars back in the day.
You know,
like the 1959 Cadillac,
I'm sure that that car was lighter
than your average Toyota Camry.
So anyways, this, somebody sent me,
let me, let me, you read this guy's,
this guy's response here. One
of the many that I got. Um,
on the gas mileage thing, it always blows
my mind what people fucking respond to.
So this guy ends up writing me a,
he goes, there are two reasons.
Wait a minute,
it's loading.
Okay,
loading.
I don't know.
He gave me all these fucking reasons
and I basically responded with so basic,
you're telling me, he basically said
that it had nothing to do with money.
It had to do with the weight of the cars
and somehow the mixture of the gasoline
that we use nowadays.
That's why they just can't figure out a
fucking way to get more than like better
than what's the highest you've seen?
Like 40 45 this guy tried to say,
well,
actually there are things
that can a hundred miles to
gallon their scooters. Ah,
what it more rod?
He goes,
there's two reason why old cars have
such highly high published gas mileage.
For one, the EPA tests simply
used to provide higher numbers.
Sir, they've been doing
that right up until the last
couple of years ago. In fact,
the year before I bought my Prius,
they were legally able to claim that it
got like 55th I actually almost 60 miles
per gallon before they cracked down
on the hybrid and made him say,
actually 40 ones.
I'm aware of the EPA test.
I'm aware that they do it
when there's no headwind.
I'm aware that most of the test is when
they're fucking going 25 miles an hour
and they only drive the car 55 miles
an hour for about fucking 30 seconds.
I realize that the numbers are skewed.
Okay.
He said it's been revised several times
over the decade. Yeah. So my Prius,
your Prius would get like 70
miles per gallon on the old
test. No, it wasn't, sir.
No, it wouldn't. It would get more
like 60 that's what it did. Look.
So let's just say that it would
get 70 who gives a shit? He goes,
what? Where am I? The second
reason is safety features.
Check out the weight of your vehicles.
Cars have gotten heavier. No, they have.
My Prius is not heavier than a
fucking Subaru and the 1970s it isn't.
Okay,
dude, I'm old enough to remember when cars
actually had metal on their dashboard.
They're all plastics hunks shit now.
Okay.
He goes, cars, if even 15 years ago,
feature death traps when compared
to the modern cars. No, they didn't.
They've had to crumple free zones.
There's those little crumpled freak.
They've had those crumple zones for years,
sir.
In 19 fucking 88 I was coming home from
a Christmas party drunk off my ass,
sitting in the fucking passenger
seat of a Pontiac Grand Prix.
We pulled up to a red light.
There was a fucking jeep CJ seven
the old school ones sitting there.
All right, we saw it, I
saw it, the driver's side,
but the alcohol didn't quite
see it and we just sorta went.
We were slowing down,
but we didn't come to a complete stop
and just completely rear ended this guy.
All right? There wasn't a
scratch on the fucking jeep.
This goddamn Karch folded
up like a fucking accordion.
The engine dropped down
underneath us and I, I got,
I didn't even get a booboo. I
just Sorta, you know, I didn't,
I didn't have a seatbelt on or nothing.
The car was designed to take
80% of the fucking impact.
All right, you're sitting in your cubicle.
Just toss in these fucking numbers out.
All right.
So basically my response is,
I'm saying it has nothing to do
with money in the oil companies.
So basically what you're telling me
is that nowadays I can have a video
conference with somebody in Brazil.
Why my entire music collection is in my
pocket on a phone that is also a camera
and a video recorder.
I can upload the content onto the
Internet and potentially have it viewed by
every person in the fucking world.
But we can't make a car that does
any better than 40 miles per gallon.
So fortunately, you know, everything
else has fucking progressed
except for gas mileage.
Dude, I'm telling you,
they have the technology to
get like 500 miles per gallon.
They're just not going to fucking put
it out because that's how powerful the
Goddamn oil companies are there.
Right up there with the banks.
You've got the banks and then
you've got the oil company.
The banks control the money
supply and then the oil companies,
they control energy.
Okay,
okay. You control energy. You can,
you control the fucking population.
Do you know that? They're
actually out here. There's people,
they're selling kits out here to have
your own fucking windmill so you can get
yourself off the grid. So then they
immediately pass the fucking law,
General Electric,
that General Electric had to come around
and make sure that everything was safe.
They had to get their
fucking noses back in there.
So cause they can't have people
disappearing off the fucking grid.
You can't have people getting free
energy other than the cost of the fucking
wind mill.
You can't have them sitting there.
And every time the God damn wind blows it,
it recharges a generator.
And now I don't have to work as much.
I don't have to work as much.
I don't have to go into debt.
You're getting yourself off of the fucking
treadmill and they can't have that.
All right.
God Damn it.
I wish I was more intelligent so I could
explain this better. But you know what?
This is a great documentary.
I'm actually going to email this guy back.
It's called the gas
whole full documentary,
and there's the date and
they have everything from,
they have everything from the,
the,
the urban myth of the
watered powered carburetor,
which this guy who I brought
to me completely dismissed.
He completely dismissed any sort
of, uh, that, that, that, that,
that exists because he sits in a cubicle
and I sit in the fucking bedroom.
All right? And he tries to
just say, that's just another
media hoax. All, you know,
they said, do we beat Eisenhower?
A fucking like dumb shit like that.
Okay. This. So this documentary,
I have everything from like
the urban myths that the,
that these a water powered cars existed.
Um,
all the way up to actual, uh, retired, um,
scientists who worked for Shell.
Okay?
Who, you just have to watch this
documentary. They were shown,
there was a book out that claimed that
they could get a 149 miles per gallon in
the 1950s on like a Packard or desoto.
And by the 70s,
this scientist who worked for Shell
said they had gotten it up to a thousand
miles per gallon.
All right.
I don't know why people think that it's,
it's
okay.
Absolutely impossible to improve the
gas mileage. Some people feel that,
I don't know why people feel like we can't
come up with anything better than the
gas combustion engine.
It's complete fucking book.
It's the same level of bullshit as that.
There's an actual difference between
a Democrat and a Republican watch this
documentary,
the gas hole.
We're going to have the link up
on the Monday morning podcast.
Just watch this shit and I don't know
what to tell you. Some of it looks like,
okay. Did they have this
old guy going, you know,
and this guy showed up and he had, it
was a contraption made auto, you know,
it was powered on water and then he
claimed that Shell bought the patent,
gave him $1 million, and then he
could never fucking, you know,
make another one now.
That's the kind of Shit,
some old guy saying that he saw it on
a salt flat in the 1950s I'm not going
with that. All right. I'm not
that much of a fucking whack job.
But when a guy who worked used to work
for Shell is coming out saying that type
of stuff, it's just, it gets to the
point like, are all of these people nuts?
Okay.
You know what I mean?
There's no fucking way.
I don't give a shit whether there's led
and gas, whether there's not letting gas,
how much the car fucking ways or any of
that bullshit. There's no fucking way.
Yeah.
That in, in, in almost 40 years,
you can't do better than
two more miles per gallon.
I absolutely fucking refused
to believe it. I rap.
I fucking refuse to believe it.
I think it's complete horseshit.
It's just another way to s to
keep control of the herd. Now,
if you want to argue that you need to
keep control the herd or there's going to
be absolute chaos,
so we have to keep cars down like that.
I will listen to that argument.
But if you're going to come at me
and tell me that in 2000 fucking 11
okay, when I'm reading shit
that in the medical field,
they can now grow a fucking a new
colon for somebody outside of the body.
I read this,
this thing on that ted.com this woman had
a completely ulcerated large intestine,
so they took some sort of tissue,
CARF culture,
whatever the fuck that means
out of her of diseased colon.
Use that to then grow another one
outside of her body where they would done
growing it. They took the old
one out and put the new one in,
like she went down to midas muffler
and it totally fucking worked okay.
Up until like five years ago,
you were looking at a colostomy bag.
You would have a bag of shit
right under her fucking right,
tinny for the rest of her God damn life.
Her social life would have been over.
Okay.
If they can do that,
you're telling me you're still going to
tell me they can't do anything rather
than about 40 fucking 45 miles a gallon.
You're really going to sit there and
believe that in your Goddamn cubicle that
they just can't fucking,
just can't fucking figure it out.
The only way I can get like a hundred
miles a gallon is if I ride on a fucking
scooter. You sir, believe in Santa Claus.
I remember one time I had this
old piece of shit truck, right,
that I drove for like 10 years because
I knew I wanted to be a comedian and I
didn't want to go into debt.
So when the engine finally died,
I threw a new engine in there and the
guy told me he needed to rebuild the
carburetor.
I'm like,
you don't need to rebuild the carburetor
so you know what this cunt did.
He fucking adjusted the carburetors.
So I would just get shitty gas mileage
hoping I would be an absolute
fucking moron and then
drive back and I'll be like,
well, I guess you're right. I'm just,
I'm just chowing through gas here.
That's what this mother fucker did
at his little garage.
This little piece of shit did that because
it wasn't enough that he fucking made
1600 fucking bucks off me.
He wanted to make like fucking 1900 bucks.
So he did that just as a
fucking individual and you're
going to try and tell me
that a corporation that basically
controls the world fucking energy.
He's not going to buy up patents
by people that that are, that are,
that are are making or coming up with
the carburetors and stuff like carb.
But by coming up with,
with with alternate ways of
powering a car more efficiently,
they're not going to buy that up. Do
they have that whole Stanley mayor thing?
And that's not a conspiracy theory either.
We actually,
we actually played the news
clip on the opiate Anthony show.
Stanley mayor,
great news for individuals,
but bad news for oil companies claims
he's come up with an engine that can run
on any type of water,
fresh water, salt water,
rainwater doesn't make a difference
and he claims he can drive across the
country on 28 gallons of water.
Um,
this is of such interest. The Pentagon is
sending a lieutenant colonel out there.
That was the actual news clip
from the opiate Anthony show.
It was an actual news clip.
It's not some bullshit I read
on a fucking website. Okay.
Now what happened after that?
Nobody knows.
But basically within 10 years Stanley
was dead in his car disappeared and his
brother right now is trying to get the
car back and nobody knows where the fuck
it is. All right. Um, I,
I truly believe that the quickest death
sentence you could possibly have is to
go on the news and claim that you've come
out with an alternate source of energy
that's going to put a corporation
out of business that is making,
that is projected to make
$350 billion next year.
How much do you think your life is worth?
And if you have $350 billion,
how easy is it do you think to get
somebody to solve this problem?
Now, if you're new to my
podcast last week, I was saying,
how come miles per gallon on gas
on cars, sorry, as it's been,
it's basically been
the same since the 70s.
So people were trying to suggest to me
that cars weighed more back in the 70s.
And I said, get the fuck Outta here.
Those God damn led back in the day.
They had metal bumpers and full size
spares. Get the fuck Outta here.
I remember when we had,
uh,
we had like a 72 or 73 Buick
regal to door and it took two.
Me and one of my brothers,
all of our might to open that fucking
car doors like opened up God damn like a
bank vault.
But two things I forgot to do.
One actually look up the stats and to
realize that I was like fucking six years
old when I was trying to open it.
You know you ever think that
shit when you think it doesn't,
it doesn't really snow as much as it
used to, which it probably doesn't.
But as far as like the storm spent by you,
like dude back in the day
was up to my waist. Yeah.
And you were about three feet
tall. That's why. That's why,
that's why it seems so
fucking deep because you could
barely look over a coffee
table. Um, anyway, so I'll
give you guys that one.
I'll give you guys that one.
Okay.
And I would actually love to be wrong on
this one, but I just don't think I am.
Even though I was wrong that that cars
weighed more in the 70 when people show
me a bunch of stats, cause God knows
I'm not going to look at them all right.
And people,
by the way,
who actually said that I really
sounded like a moron last week. I May,
I invite you to listen to the first four
years of this podcast and just see the
reoccurring theme that that is. Okay.
I don't read it makes me sleepy.
I've stated that before. I don't fucking
read. All right? I go with my gut.
Okay. I'll tell you this right now.
I don't know how to fill a tooth,
but I can go in and look at
a dentist and real and I can,
I can fucking judge that guy.
Whether or not he's gonna he's,
he's telling me the truth.
Does that make any sense?
Of course it doesn't go fuck yourself.
I've got a God damn hour to fill here.
This is what,
this is a problem I have,
I have with people who are defending
the oil companies here is basically when
you go back to the 70s okay?
And you prove to me the cars.
Did they weigh more now? Okay,
so you're right on that one.
Yeah.
But your logic though is still based in
that the oil companies were telling the
truth in 1976 that whatever 35 miles per
gallon was the best that we could do.
So you use that as a jump off point to
then prove your point now that that's why
cars get the gas mileage that that,
that,
that they get today is basically,
I have to make the leap with you that
oil companies are telling the truth,
that there's $350 billion industry.
Okay.
That that has
on numerous occasions openly got
in the way of any sort of progress.
I remember here out in California,
I think it was the late nineties
it might've been 20 years ago.
I can't remember what it was before I
moved out here the first time or right
after I left.
The air quality out here
was so fucking horrific.
It's like I know a lot of people
still think it's real smoggy out here.
It definitely gets smog,
but it usually just in the summertime,
and it's definitely hazy out here,
but Hays is not fucking smog.
Smog is Brown.
You go hiking and you feel a burning
in your fucking chest back in the day,
in the late nineties. Okay. You could
see this shit. So anyway, so they, they,
they put this,
uh,
they put it to the vote for a people to
the people who actually would vote on
this shit and they pass this
bill that said by the year 2000,
whatever,
25% or 30% of cars had to
run on something other than,
you know, the gas oil could get
basically the gas combustion engine.
They basically paved the way for the
big three to then basically start making
electric cars the fucking thing past.
Okay.
An oil companies got together with their
lobbyists and they went and they just
totally dismantled the whole thing
and the whole thing fucking went away.
Okay.
Okay. Which for all you people out
there who are gonna explain capitalism,
capitalism to me, I get it. That
is their prerogative to do that.
Why wouldn't they get in the way of that?
So let me ask you this.
You're telling me that they would get
in the way of that but they wouldn't get
in the way of any sort of progress.
Just with the gas combustion engine,
they wouldn't get in a way of
any of that type of progress.
They seem to not get in the
way of anything else. Safety,
they don't give a shit about. They won't
get in the way of that type of stuff.
Burning it cleaner. They don't give
a fuck about but miles per gallon,
which is their bottom line like do
you guys honestly think like today,
like what your car gets like that's
honestly the best that science can do that
is we are right up against the fucking
wall. Is that what you're telling me?
You know, considering if they
just even increased it by five,
10 miles a gallon per every new car,
that they would immediately lose
hundreds of millions of dollars.
Why would they do it? Why would they
do? Why would they allow that to happen?
Why wouldn't they get in the way of that?
That's all I'm asking here.
And you know something for all
you fucking assholes out there.
Who called me this? Whack job conspiracy
theories. These are my conspiracies.
Bankers are fucking evil.
Well,
companies lie to you and insurance
companies are pieces of shit.
That's basically my three.
And then they have enough money
to basically buy elections.
That's basically yet,
okay. Those really aren't
groundbreaking conspiracies are they?
I'm not saying that some guy
living in the fucking moon.
I'm not saying I saw a fucking flying
saucer come out of the God damn emotion.
It fucking take a piss on somebody
sunbae then and then, you know,
I saw Ronald Reagan waving out the
side of it and then it took off.
I'm not saying that shit, I
just, I don't buy it. Okay.
And I actually got emails from
people. Um, they sent me these,
these, these links, they
sent me this link of this,
this fucking kid,
14 year old kid with one of his classmates
built this futuristic looking Jetsons
car and they got close to 2000
miles per gallon. I'll, I'll,
I'll send you the link to this.
You can go on the [inaudible]
podcast and look at this thing. Mm,
the MM podcast.com
look at the picture of this thing.
Okay. And once you'd done saying, well,
it's not a practical car,
it's not as heavy as the other ones.
It would never meet the safety
standards and Yada, Yada, Yada,
all that fucking shit.
Do you honestly think that airbags,
navigation systems,
crumple zones and all that?
You're honestly going to tell me that
that basically knocks off 1900 miles per
gallon.
Are you really going to fucking sit
there and tell me that you honestly think
that they're not?
Why wouldn't they get in the way of it?
They have the money to get in the way
in the way of it. And not only that,
they're not even part of this
country in a way. They're borderless.
They're, they're worldwide.
I don't, I don't know.
So I decided, I, I respectfully
apologize for not fucking, uh,
looking up the weight of the car.
I was 100% wrong in that,
but I still do not think that I'm
wrong or I'm fucking paranoid.
I had one guy, this guy is fucking
hilarious. This guy was just ripping me,
just saying, this is classic old
man. It's like, dude, I'm 43.
Jesus Christ, this guy's going old
man. Like I'm afraid of the world.
I'm afraid of the fucking world I have.
I at least can sit here and tell you that
I don't believe in all that religious
horse shit.
What if I was a scared old man?
What'd I be going to church every God
damn week when I be doing that stuff?
Believing in the immaculate conception.
I think you go on the ground people.
I, you know what that's, that's my theory.
I think when you died you go in the ground
and then you become a fossil fuel for
more people to fucking fight
in, in, in, in a lie about the,
the do you know,
you know,
and my actually my Prius and I've
actually thought about doing this.
There's people granted it
fucks over your warrant, your,
your warranty on your car.
They can actually get a
hundred miles per gallon bay.
And basically what they do is they just,
uh,
they just fill the ass end with
a bunch of batteries, you know?
Okay.
Which I'm sure those are
great for the environment.
Oh, you know what it is people, I think
you know what? It comes down to the most.
Why is my fucking throat so dry?
Hang on a second.
Okay.
I think it comes down to the
amount of what we do. We're fucked.
But I just think that there's certain
entities that just have too much fucking
power.
I think when you start making $350
billion a year and you're nationwide,
at some point some sort of government
should have some sort of power over you.
And I don't really think
that are ours does. I don't,
I don't think that they have any fucking
pile. Well, what are they going to do?
They got us by the balls the
second you start giving them shit,
they put their hand on the, on the
nozzle, the spicket good. Keep talking.
We're goodness. We'll shut
this fucking thing off. Huh?
Do you want to pay
$9,000 for a cantaloupe?
Shut your face for 25 gallon. Go
Fuck Yourself. Next question. Yes.
This is our Marnie. MMM.
[inaudible] alright,
plowing ahead here. I really want
you guys to look at this. Okay?
You guys who actually fucking do research.
Um,
like here's one guy
tells me the 1987 Honda,
CRX got 57 miles on the highway.
Wait was 1800 pounds.
The 2011 CRX miles per gallon is 41 on
the highway and it weighs 2,600 pounds.
So I, I see, I see. They're
fucking argument. So right
there it's like, all right,
well the car was fucking 800 more pounds,
which is a lot when the first
one only wait 1800 you almost,
you're talking about, was
that 40% boys? 40% more?
Is it getting 40% less
on the gas? No, it isn't.
So that's actually a fucking improvement.
I will give you that.
But the jump off point, I'm not
buying it. I'm not buying that.
We can only get 15 to 25 miles
a gallon in 1975 I don't buy it.
I bet they easily could've got 200 at
that point. They're not going to do it,
dude. You talking about the
blue bloods at that point?
You're talking about that level
of fucking power. All right.
My apologies to everybody out there
who actually has some sort of science
background. Evidently people told
me that that Stan Stanley Mayer,
the water power car is
junk science and it's,
it's absolutely ridiculous as some would
even suggest that they could do that.
Uh, so I lost on that one. So
this, so you'd, so you guys,
you guys want two thirds of the
argument here with me. All right.
So now that you've backed
me into the corner,
I want you to explain to me
why oil companies wouldn't
stand in the way of that
technology and w and two fold and why
you believe that what they tell you that
cars get is the best that we can do.
Why you believe that we can't
get 60 miles per gallon?
Well,
you know,
there's air airbag and other things
and satellite flying around us.